many pregnant women are questioning
whether to get the coronavirus vaccine
right now there's only limited data on
how safe it is for them
the cdc says women have a low risk of
getting severe
illnesses from covid but that risk is
significantly greater
for pregnant women cbs news senior
medical correspondent dr tara narula
spoke with a pregnant nurse about why
she decided to get the vaccine
the theoretical risks of the vaccine
did not outweigh the known risks of
coded
megan garabay is a registered nurse and
infection preventionist at comanche
county memorial hospital in lawton
oklahoma
she's eight and a half months pregnant
and received her first dose of the
pfizer vaccine
last month i've got a much higher chance
of suffering severe consequences
or even death from covid than i do from
suffering severe consequences from this
vaccine
garabay had a mild reaction from the
vaccine and will receive her
final dose today did you initially have
any hesitation
about getting the vaccine while pregnant
initially i would say
there was some hesitation just because i
mean at the very beginning i kind of
felt like everyone else said that
the vaccine may have been a little bit
rushed but once i had the data in my
hands
that hesitation really went away garebay
says that the clinical trial
research done on non-pregnant women
convinced her to get the vaccine
but there is no safety or efficacy data
on how pregnant women and nursing
mothers
will respond to these vaccines because
they were excluded from clinical trials
the cdc says pregnant women can choose
to get vaccinated
and the american college of
obstetricians and gynecologists advises
that covet 19 vaccines
should not be withheld from pregnant
women but for 31 year old taiwo odasanya
the lack of data concerns her she's 35
weeks pregnant with her first child
and says she wouldn't get the vaccine if
it was offered
we don't know what long-term respect
even look like
for pregnant women as a whole so we
certainly don't know what long-term
effects look like
for you know fetuses pregnancy already
comes with its own anxieties and risks
but now for women like odasanya the
pandemic
and the new vaccines add another layer
of concern
but i think the other side of that too
is when
the risk of well what if you are
pregnant and you do get covered
and i think if i were in month three i'd
be more inclined to take it
just because we see so many horrible
things happening to
um you know adult people who have
coveted the vaccine really is our best
way of preventing coven 19. dr laura
riley is an ob guy
at new york presbyterian she says even
with the lack of data
the benefits of the vaccines are very
likely to outweigh the risk
of covid19 the biology of the way this
vaccine
works does not make us think in any way
that this vaccine is going to be any
less safe
or any less efficacious in pregnancy
than it is in non-pregnant individuals
and dr tara narula joins us now tara
good morning
this i can see how this is such a
difficult choice for women here what is
the best advice for pregnant women and
nursing mothers at this point
it is a difficult decision and anthony
it's one that really is a personal
decision
and we talk about shared decision making
which means that a woman should sit down
with her ob
gyn and have a discussion about the
risks and the benefits and when we talk
about risks we're talking about what is
her risk of exposure is she a front line
worker
is she in a job where she's out in the
community where there's high
transmission
how far along is she in the pregnancy
what are her underlying medical
conditions that might put her at
even a higher risk and then there should
be a frank discussion about what the
risks of covid to pregnant women in
general
are and what data or lack of data we
have in terms of safety
so it is that really back and forth
discussion with her provider that's
going to help her make that personal
choice
all right dr tara narula thanks